invidious g-force partner program is
leading adding word partners to charge
more for AMD GPUs welcome to Horus
hobbies you may have heard of nvidia GP
but what exactly is it so basically it
is just a partnership between nvidia and
add inboard partners nvidia is offering
free publicity and early access to their
new technologies to the Attenberg
partners and in return they want admin
board partners to designate their
popular series as nvidia exclusives for
example if asus were to join then they
would have to designate their rog strict
series as convenient exclusive if msi
joined they would have to designate
their gaming x series as an nvidia
exclusive if EVGA joined they would have
to designate their for the wind cards as
an nvidia exclusive and so on and so
forth so basically nvidia is trying to
keep the popular selling card series to
themselves in order to reduce
competition from AMD even further but
obviously in video received a lot of
hate for that and a lot of resistance
and eventually nvidia ended up ending
the GPP however within that time frame
some part however within that time frame
some ad board partners already joined
the program and always start developing
alternative card series for AMD one such
company was asus and a series that they
developed was called ares and they
already announced the every series way
back in april but Vidya didn't cancel
GPP until May and by the time in via
cancelled GP p in May
Asus had already spent a good amount of
money developing and designing this new
series thus they decided to continue
developing the Ares series and those
cards are finally hitting the market and
how much does this cost
well the asus ares variant of the AMD
Vega 64 GPU comes in at 750 dollars
things have gotten better and now it's
that offered at 650 but that's still a
lot more than MSRP at over 150 dollars
and this is where the problem lies
if GPP were still in place then asus
would have a lot more time to recuperate
all the designing cause that is spent to
develop ares but since GPP got cancelled
asus is probably not continuing the Ares
series into the future and they're
having to recuperate all the costs as
soon as possible in a short period of
time and in the end that is causing
these GPUs to be a lot more than MSRP on
top of this the asus area series is kind
of like a limited edition offering of
the rog series and as a result asus is
trying to take advantage of that as well
and make more off of this whether it is
out of necessity or greed asus wouldn't
have even designed this series if vidya
didn't start GBP and as a result GPP is
really the root cause of these inflated
prices that we're seeing right now so
what's the big deal it's just one car
series right there are many other car
series from other companies well this is
where the chain effect takes place the
rog strict series and rog era series are
pretty much identical even in design
pretty much and as a result those two
cars can't have a big price disparity or
the Ares just won't sell and as a result
Asus will have to maintain the rog
strict series at a high price as long as
the Ares is on the market because people
are only willing to spend so much for a
novelty feature like a limited edition
offer and after that people will just go
back to value and just buy the ROG Strix
and as a result asus has to maintain a
small price disparity between the two
card series and if Asus is insistent on
maintaining such high prices for their
flagship rog strict series then why
would EVGA or MSI want to lower that
instead these other companies would also
maintain their high-end flagship cards
at those inflated prices as well because
they can get away with it too you may be
like well why doesn't one company just
undercut two other companies but that'll
produce more sales and profit for
themselves well these are all big
companies and they know that a price
race will just hurt all of
them in the long run plus long-term
consistent sales is much better for them
than short-term boosted sales because
even if their get boosted sales from
lowering their prices eventually another
company will undercut them once more and
that cycle will keep continuing and
really no one will wait for them
overall the Asus Aires series is on the
expensive side because of the extra
manufacturing and designing costs or
just opportunity and greed
either way the oranges truth series is
pretty much identical
and as a result Asus can't get away with
in a big price disparity between the two
series and as a result they have to
maintain both Teresa inflated prices and
if a 2 is getting away with such prices
other companies are going to start to do
this as well instead of just laying the
GPU prices drop as market prices across
the border going down in the end
nvidia geforce partner program is
leading to AMD GPUs being stuck at
inflated prices so how do you guys feel
about this are you angry that Nvidia
doesn't have any good competition or do
you not really care because they are
just ami GPUs and ami Vega isn't really
that good compared to Nvidia in the
first place and plus aim D Vega GPUs for
overpriced since they're released pretty
much make sure comment down below how
you guys feel because I do read all my
comments I'm curious as to what you guys
think so make sure to post your thoughts
also if you guys like this video make
sure drop a like and consider
subscribing if you would like to see
more videos just like this one but until
next time bye
[Music]